Jeff was writing in Evan and Stephen how
do you overcome the crushing feeling of
despair well running and trying to grow
a business you no longer like her enjoy
oh that's why that's that's it because I
think the reality is being an
entrepreneur it is a roller coaster ice
water ups and downs is the day of
fantastic achievements you go on YouTube
channel you go on your facebook you feel
invigorated the next day something wax
use some resins someone comes out your
competitor or you lose a couple
something happens where you get a bad
review on social media and you know it
can be crushed I kind of think that's
what we talked about you gotta pick
yourself up dust yourself off from crack
on because we're all passionate about
fun but if it's genuinely kind of
despair then I think if it's got to a
stage you've got to ask yourself am I
still passionate about this business if
not think about well what's the
appropriate exit because again what do
we do we spend two-thirds three-quarters
of our conscious lives working working
for them in our dreams we're not being
true to ourselves if we know what we're
pursuing is something when I'm ash so
you know ultimately if someone comes
along else to buy the company that's
probably a good exit and you should do
that go and start the new gig of
suddenly you're passionate yeah I
totally agree the key thing in the
question there was at the end so running
the business that you no longer like her
and joy you know if you don't like her
and her we're doing you're never going
to be great at it so get up if it's at
the point where you can sell it great
salad if not then didn't close shop and
go do something that that makes you come
alive when you are passionate about it
because the feeling is only gonna get
worse if you feel like it's despair and
crushing right now it's only going to
get worse too long you keep doing
something that you are not in love with